welcome everybody we are standing by for
Donald Trump s press secretary Kayleigh
McKenna knee at the top of the hour I am
very very interested in how she is going
to handle questions that some may call
nasty about the president's complete
lack of leadership in the midst not only
of the corona virus pandemic but now
national unrest dozens of cities with
protests confrontations between
protesters and looters police and
looters police and protesters media
getting shot with rubber bullets Donald
Trump so far a complete and embarrassing
total lack of leadership sitting at the
White House tweeting about he's gonna
it's essentially like the Simpsons
released the hounds remember that
episode if people used to watch The
Simpsons
Smithers release the hounds Trump
tweeting we're gonna send vicious dogs
after protesters as well as bloodthirsty
Secret Service agents we put the young
ones on the front lines Donald Trump
sang an embarrassing lack of leadership
meanwhile Joe Biden who's no progressive
hero has actually been tweeting
conciliatory things and went out and
kneeled with protesters and spoke with
protesters to figure out what it is that
is going on and so we can all as
reasonable people disagree about what
the right tactics should be there is a
position which has been the closest to
my position for a long time that if the
democratic system is still functioning
rather than destruction of property we
should use that system to get a
different mayor in Minneapolis to put in
a different police chief etc that being
said I say that from a position of
privilege I understand at this point how
things are boiling over and I have a
number of commentaries on my broadcast
show today and I think one other
important thing we want to keep in mind
as we think about the protests is you
know protesters are protesting and
looters are looting and we don't even
have to get
to this game of is looting a valid form
of protest don't even let them pull you
into these philosophical black holes and
semantic vicious circles protesters are
protesting and we have video of them
from look Brooklyn and other places
saying we are not here to engage with
the police we are not here to break the
law period that's it you see anybody
doing that stuff you call them out
separately you have looters looting for
sure and it is really important that we
not fall into phrases like the
protesters are looting no the looters
are looting and the protesters are
protesting and there are opportunists
here who are trying to take advantage of
the situation in addition we have to be
really careful this phrase out of town
Earth is being used to devalue the
purpose of these protests when you say
the as many right-wingers have been
saying these are out of town people
coming in what they're saying is people
aren't genuinely in in their community
mad about what's going on in their
community they're out-of towners vague
provocateurs from out of town we can't
allow that term to also be used to
disqualify the validity of why
protesters are protesting of course okay
Kaylee Maggie and Annie scheduled for
the top of the hour welcome to everybody
just joining me now there is some
stunning leaked audio of Donald Trump on
a call today with governor's these are
the rantings of a lunatic take a listen
to trump encouraging violence against
protesters
[Music]
from just like gleeful about you know
riot riot police and riot gear and
oppress it's crazy
that's that's not true he famously lives
in Florida by the way Trump seems to
have like a New York accent we don't
normally hear when he nor this is
anybody else is picking up on that
[Music]
dominate him you got to dominate him
something I guess Trump knows knows a
thing or two about I don't know so there
there is that and Donald Trump that
leaked audio there and we're gonna be
covering that on the program tomorrow of
course let me see what's on people's
minds from the standpoint of twitch and
YouTube messages over on Twitch thanks
to G Bell flowers and basta foo and
toady Capote further twitch prime
subscriptions a couple of uh super chats
coming in nasty questions
says prediction Kaley will show up later
than ever and the press briefing will be
the shortest one yet she cannot handle
nasty questions sad Antonio Jose Franco
says why does low voter turnout hurt
Democrats is it entirely targeted
suppression or is there also a component
of Democratic voters voting less
reliably that's a very complex question
I've addressed the that a number of
times and you can check out videos about
it on my channel Casey says are you
going to do a video on the Trump Epstein
stuff that's come out and have you read
the documents I have read the documents
listen I talked about Trump being
accused of raping a 13 year old years
ago so to me none of it is really new
Waller is me says do you think the
protests where people may or may not be
wearing masks may or may not be socially
distancing will give Trump and out if
coronavirus cases increase yes Donald
Trump is set to blame the protests for
coronavirus spikes which may or may not
happen
thanks to easy NXT and that's me 1 2 3 4
subscribing over on Twitch Carl Smith
says do you support the protests what
factors do you think led to the
escalation to rioting so yes of course
how can I not support something that is
protected by the Constitution the right
to peaceably assemble and demand that
your concerns be heard now I have never
supported bio physical violence
I have never supported criminality of
any kind and so my my position at this
point is I still maintain that I am
against violence and criminality and I
question whether it will achieve
anything and I sympathize with the
degree of desperation over the systems
that have failed in the United States
such that I get why we are seeing what
we are seeing and it is not something
that I recommend but I say that
knowingly from a position of privilege
and it's extremely important that these
issues not be mixed up I have a 20 min
video that's coming I don't want to redo
it cuz I just recorded it it's gonna
come out later anybody who claims to
have the enlightened hot take on what
this is really about is ignoring
something and what I mean by that is
there are people who say this is merely
about this is a race problem in the
United States others say this is a
police-brutality problem in the United
States you have others who say this is a
capitalism problem in the United States
capitalism inevitably leads to this in
the United States others say the problem
is militarization of law enforcement
these are all problems these are all
problems they interact with each other
and we will not really understand what
needs to happen if we continue to claim
I know what the real thing is here it's
not those other four things the real
issue is just X or Y or whatever the
these are big big problems and I hope
that I do justice to some of those
factors in the video clip that I
recorded earlier and will be going up I
think at 4:00 p.m. Eastern Time
okay I am seeing I'm seeing people get
the banhammer dropped on them that's
good because we see a lot a lot of
people are spreading a lot of uh
essentially fomenting violence in the
chat so the moderators are my deputized
to drop the banhammer
I want to thank frozen pop-tart tides
and space invader for supporting on
Twitch where we have a hype train
happening right now
Aaron das says over on YouTube 30 second
explanation and Tifa equals terrorists
is that legal
I don't think so I don't believe so so
when Trump says we are going to
designate an Tifa a terrorist group what
he's talking about is the Department of
State's foreign terrorist organizations
antia is a domestic group with American
citizens doing things on US soil so even
though I've been critical of many of
their tactics before designating them as
Trump wants to designate them a
terrorist group would deny them both due
process and First Amendment rights and
my understanding is that
would not be constitutional for Trump to
do that Bob to 25-ish says things are
bad downtown Sacramento was ransacked
horrible or I mean here in Boston we are
seeing absolutely horrible things take
place
Paul Carroll has become a SOI boy level
membership member on YouTube rather
parity reign from Sweden says thank you
for being the voice of reason in this
trying time I'm doing my best my friend
doing my best and very much appreciate
your support we are standing by for
Kayleigh Magon Annie
McKenna knee McKenna and Anna and Annie
as some like to say I believe it has
potentially been pushed to the bottom of
the hour originally scheduled for five
minutes ago but that's okay we're all
here and there is there is so much to
talk about
mat shava says I really hope all those
protesting register and vote and vote
blue all the way down all this will be
for nothing if every single person
doesn't vote I agree with you so here is
again a lot of this stuff I did on my
podcast today I hope that you guys know
by the way we do an hour a day free
podcast free it's for anybody if you
want the pot get the podcast it's free
you can find it on iTunes stitcher
Google Play and in that our podcast
about 20 minutes today is dedicated to
all of the different aspects to what is
going on right now and one of the things
that I point out is when you look in
history when these big activism
movements get going which sometimes
include tactics and actions that we
don't agree with sometimes include
sit-ins and other types of activism etc
very often at the tail end of it it
comes down to a Supreme Court making a
decision a beautiful perfect example I
had this I had a perfect phone call
where we discussed this example earlier
1954 s Brown V Board of Education
decision okay bear with me here I think
this is important in 1954 the Supreme
Court under Earl Warren decided in Brown
v Board of Ed
ocation schools at the state level
cannot racially segregated ama will have
a black school and a white school
Supreme Court decided that in 1954
depended on not a 9-0 decision because
of the previous presidents who had put
people on the court in 1954 they all
came together and made this decision
what led to brown v board of education
started you could argue in 1951
it started with protests it started with
nonviolent resistance
it started with sit-ins it started with
appealing to elected officials it
started with some protests that we would
certainly consider over the line by the
same standards that we use today that
was 1951 and then it worked its way
through activists became elected to
local office and court cases started and
next thing you know it's 1954 and the
Supreme Court says Brown v Board of
Education 9-0 school segregation is not
legal period it is over so you all know
where I'm what I'm getting to everything
that's going on now let's have a healthy
debate about what are what are the right
and wrong tactics let's not allow the
right to invalidate and disqualify the
motivations of the protesters who are
protesting but let's remember that in
two or three years whatever it is we
want as the end goal here may come down
to who is on the Supreme Court who is on
different federal benches judges and
that is going to be determined over the
next few years either by Donald Trump
for another for if he gets reelected or
by Joe Biden it's pretty clear who is
going to appoint the right people given
the two options that we have just listen
to what Joe Biden's been saying and
tweeting over the last 24 hours he's not
perfect he sponsored the crime bill in
1994 I get it but the options we have
are these and there is essentially no
comparison so that is my you know in the
back of all this let's not lose sight of
the forest
for the trees as as as the term may be
okay other super chats coming in let's
see here Sean sac has subscribed pyro
plasma or plasma as I like to call it
and Tifa has no central organization or
leadership yeah the idea that an Tifa is
even a cohesive organization also is a
reason why it's hard to put him on any
kind of list but yeah I get the point
Townsend Kok says antifa terror
designation is crazy and unlikely thank
god were sufficiently enlightened
society that level legal heads will
prevail when the dust settles yeah Trump
said he's gonna do it I don't think he's
actually gonna do it he says I mean it's
it's you know it's red meat it's
throwing red meat out to people team a
BBC Taekwondo says with deployment of
the military be political suicide the
National Guard has already been deployed
remember the National Guard is they are
State National Guards and many of them
have already been deployed I don't think
what's going on now is particularly good
for Trump Trump is presiding over chaos
and he is impotent and flaccid in doing
anything to take control of the
situation
Casey Bates says I believe Trump is
terrible but I can't help to feel like
I'm just the person that was so anti
Obama in 2008 / 2012 was it this bad
then with Obama the the hatred of Obama
was from people on the Left who thought
Obama abandoned leftist ideas he ran on
and lunatics on the right who were a
combination of you know racist
xenophobic and just extreme libertarians
who believed the government doing
anything is socialism or communism so no
it is a very very different situation
eran da da says Magga night seemed like
a total flop whomp-whomp
yeah this was so funny Trump tweeted
Saturday night in rephrasing it was
basically just a call for the Magus
supporters to get to the White House in
a show of power nobody showed up and
then Trump stopped tweeting for 13 hours
the longest he went without
in a long time badly badly embarrassing
okay other uh people supporting on
Twitch Karoshi
is supporting on Twitch quakes says does
it make me an [ __ ] if I want to join
the protests but don't want to do too
coronavirus fears no I mean no everybody
listen everybody has to make a call and
maintaining social distancing is a
relevant priority and saying it is more
important to go in support so I'm gonna
wear a mask and uh you know not not get
people sick or get sick myself
everybody's got to make the call that is
right for them pyro plasma say where'd
that go says active-duty military
deployment is illegal oh okay so you're
you're talking about not the National
Guard but active-duty military yes it is
illegal to use the military for domestic
law enforcement is my understanding
which is why it would be against the law
for Trump to deploy active-duty military
to the border for example Mac says how
does protesting actually pressure for
change well listen it it it pressures
I'm gonna throw something out there
I don't know Fox News Sunday yesterday
Chris Wallace on Fox News did an hour
where he interviewed Cornel West talked
about Cova disproportionately affecting
people of color talked about George
Floyd and the protests does Chris
Wallace do that if you don't have
protests raging I don't know that he
does I really don't I think if you have
a totally different Fox News Sunday if
you don't have these protests going on
so I think clearly mass gatherings at
urban centers do work and they get
attention
I am not supportive of destruction of
property I am obviously not supportive
of violence against police officers that
are doing nothing the the you know the
good police officers but there's no
doubt that these mass gatherings
generate attention no question about it
it's on it's every news channel for the
last four days by the way people have
been asking me to do some live streams
of
the protests and I am up for doing that
but here's the difficulty I'm having a
lot of the coverage is from nope local
news stations local news stations like
the local Fox affiliate local NBC
affiliate they are the most litigious
with copyright they will immediately
shut down my stream with a copyright
strike so if you guys are aware of
streams that are just like people
where we could see what's going on and
we can have conversations as we are
watching email them to me it's hard for
me to follow it all in all these
different platforms I would be up for
doing some of those streams but it my
channel will get shut down if I'm
restreaming local news which has been a
lot of what is covering the protests so
get in touch with me via via email I
would very much appreciate that okay let
me say some new member thank-yous I
can't thank enough the folks that signed
up in May and I want to remind you the
best way to support these streams and
the podcast and the YouTube channel in
all of it is grab a membership on my
website it's quick it's easy we estimate
only one half of one percent of our
audience currently supports via
membership so you take our total
audience you take one percent you divide
that in half 0.5% we estimate is the
level of a membership support from our
viewers if we could double that to just
one percent it would be a complete
game-changer for the show so let me
thank some folks who have signed up Tom
Nakayama is new member number one today
Barbara Schmidt bells is new member
number 2 Timothy Maura powell is new
member number 3 and vincent lin is new
member number 4 today ok I think I got
everybody you can i I believe paying
full price is a beautiful thing but I
understand everybody has a different
financial situation we don't want to
turn anybody away
so that coupon code 2020 now chops 66%
off of the cost of a membership it's
just two bucks a month or if you pay for
the year it's a doll
rady this is very very little and if
enough people do it again if we can just
go from half a percent to one percent of
our audience getting a membership we're
golden everybody will get a thank you
who signs up on my website today let's
see here
Kevin Macomb or what was wrong with the
crime bill
it's a 26 year old bill it's been years
since I did an analysis of it so you'd
have to check out my clips on it I'm not
ready to do a full analysis of the crime
bill right now dodging rains has been
watching some protest police unity video
since the corporate media keeps covering
the violent sides
yeah there's no shortage of videos where
we actually are seeing unity between
protesters and police you love to see it
you love to see it the problem of course
is that there's a lot of other things
going on as well Kurt Bollinger says
Trump wants elements of domination yeah
we played that clip earlier GK says do
you feel a sense of derealization during
all of this sometimes absolutely I mean
it's been three months we've been in
quarantine we now have violent
confrontations happening across the
entire country protesters being hit with
bullets rubber bullets media being hit
with rubber bullets media being arrested
you have looting you have rioting you
have destruction of property you have
protesters who are saying hey guys we're
here to protest we are not here to
engage with police we are not here to
break any laws call it out when you see
it you are seeing police join protesters
you're seeing police Ram protesters with
vehicles we're seeing everything and
this is why it's so tough you know a lot
of people it's it's a way to get clicks
is if I was just tweeting all day about
some grand unifying theory about what's
going on here if I pretended this is all
about race or this is all about
economics or this is all about
corruption or this is all about police
brutality you can get cliques and build
an audience that way it's just dishonest
because this is about many things and I
took 20 minutes on my podcast today the
podcast will be out very very soon the
video clip will be out much later I took
20 minutes to go through
a bunch of the different factors that
are at play here and you know what the
clip won't do that well on YouTube and a
lot of people will be bored with it but
it's it's what has to be done because
these are far more complex issues than
anybody with a this is the issue sort of
hot take is is presenting and that's not
what I want to do okay Tyler Snyder says
fun fact it's actually pronounced to
flax it yeah I always say flaccid even
though I know that it is pronounced
flaxseed it seems crazy to say flaxseed
people saying that the press briefing is
live not on any of these for any of
these three channels let's just refresh
and see oh my god she is live what's
going on here we go
and we understand that very well and
with that I'll take questions here we go
yes claimed more than 100 thousand lives
at least forty million people are
unemployed there now protests and racial
tension ripping apart many cities where
is the president why has he not
delivered in a dress do you love it as
many of his predecessors have at a time
of domestic and people won't know the
president has delivered multiple
statements on this the president as
recently as 48 hours ago without talking
about what a tragedy the death of George
Floyd was how it has weighed on his
heart on how he encourages peace and
lawfulness in our streets and in
peaceful protest so he has said that
repeatedly he's made many statements to
this effect but what I would note is
continual statements as he's made day
and day and day and day again
they don't stop anarchy what stops an
turkeys action and that's what the
president is working on right now you
said this morning that the president is
focused right now on rooting out and
Tifa George Floyd did not die in Antipa
custody he died in police
today what's the president doing to
reform policing tactics and an excessive
use of force by police yeah so it's an
important question for sure and this
president if you look today has taken
there's a civil rights investigation
into the death of Amin armory there's a
civil rights investigation into the
death of George Floyd it is a tragedy
what we saw I mentioned too that the
president was extremely upset when he
saw that burial and he continues to the
DOJ continues to pursue those charges
and he's recognized in justices for a
long time since he was a candidate he
talked about Sandra bland and what a
terrible video that was to so he
recognizes and justices where they are
but at the same time he also recognizes
that we can't allow organized groups
like an Tifa to commit some of the
heinous acts that we this is really not
about and there's a call with the
governor's the president said that he
had put general Milley in charge of all
this what does that mean yeah so
policing American streets what do you
mean so I'm not going to get ahead of
any actions that will be announced but
what I will say to you is this that he
has had two briefings today with
Secretary Esper and AG bar and general
Milley
was there men there will be additional
federal assets deployed across the
nation there will be a central command
center in conjunction with the state and
local governments that military has an
Ag bar but I won't go any further and
announcing what actions oh my what the
president meant when he told the
governor's I am quick general Milley in
charge what does that means that that
sounds like a total break here the
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
being in charge of a domestic issue and
in ensuring that as the president has
said this has been taken out of context
by the way that our streets are
dominated with a police force and with a
National Guard presence so that let me
explain a little bit about how this
works if there's a peace facility this
police will form a line what we've seen
are those lines have been overwhelmed by
massive protests that have turned into
riots the peaceful protests to be
distinguished from the riots we've seen
and when those lines are overwhelmed law
enforcement gets on the defense so what
the president has said is he wants to
dominate the streets with National Guard
with the police presence
what studies have shown as general
melody she was in that governor's call
and his his points all pertained to the
National Guard and he noted that there
are several studies that when there's an
overwhelming National Guard present that
actually de-escalates the situation and
causes less civil unrest so General
Mills huge study points and talking
about the National Guard the
effectiveness and ensuring that they're
utilized to great effect across the
country so another one other context
Karen of the Joint Chiefs is now running
domestic law enforcement okay got it got
it in charge no no I wasn't suggesting
that quote was out of context the
dominate I've seen some networks and
asked about dominating protesters and
around the president all day any time
he's used the word dominate it was with
regards to dominating the streets and
ensuring that we have peace in our
streets yes again the question remains
what exactly is the general in charge of
here
[Music]
to remain calm yeah he hasn't done that
repeatedly little talked about
understanding the pain that people are
feeling and he does understand that pain
he's talked several times about the
right to peacefully protest and I've
seen some of these peaceful protests
some of these sit-ins and it's a real
shame butl when you have anarchy and
anarchists come in and you have an Tifa
come in and it really dilutes the
message of the protesters and it's a
legitimate and Aoife is not a major
force at these things there are people
under the guise of an Tifa and they're
they're wreaking havoc but they keep
focusing on an tifa's why no one can do
anything and tifa's why Trump won't
address the nation he still plans on
going to Maine I haven't heard any other
changes to that effect yeah he does not
think there is systemic racism in law
enforcement in the u.s. does president
share that view okay I think where the
president stands is he does not believe
you fundamentally rejects the idea that
these egregious actions of these four
minnesota officers are representative of
our police force as not the question
most of our officers in this country are
good hard-working men and women who work
every day to police our streets he's
recognized cases of injustice and I
noted Sandra bland back when he was in
the primary I've known a more recently
amon armory
and then George Floyd so he recognizes
these and justices he puts a focus on
them but he also recognizes our valiant
police officers who have taken to the
streets each and every night over the
last six nights and protected our
communities
explain with the legal authority the
president has is for designating and
Tifa as a terrorist yes Jim examples
going to also talk about why he does not
want to label right supremacist groups
that are domestic so let me address the
first part about legal authority do the
18 section 2 3 3 1 allows that the term
it defines domestic terrorism as
evolving acts dangerous to human life
that appear intended to influence the
policy of a government and other
elements are laid out and it allows the
Department of Justice when utilizing
this statute to invoke greater
investigatory authority and to invoke
harsher Hirscher penalties I would note
that the Justice Department has in the
past used domestic terrorism in
consultation with acts of white
supremacy or what were racially
motivated acts like an April 20 20th
floor to man pled guilty to threatening
an African American Charlottesville City
Council candidate I mean at that time
the FBI Joint Terrorism Task Force was
utilized same in the case of February 20
2010 is the fact that the Joint
Terrorism Task Force was involved in a
prosecution is very different than Trump
designating the perpetrator a domestic
terrorist this is only the dumbest
people would fall for this [ __ ] I
explained how in this case that domestic
terrorism will be used as a way that's
true crime is prosecuted it's not a
prosecutorial method and it was utilized
in this wacky way with regard to whites
Trump's not saying it as a prosecutorial
tool he's just designating the group
they should be charged as well as the
officer who's already been charged the
other three and also on a Antipa can you
explain a little bit about how how'd he
know or how is he talking about how you
would identify members of an Tifa right
since they're a very loose organization
it would be very difficult to tell who
is part of it well so first I was just
on the call with the president where he
expressed his dismay with those three
officers who watched I'll leave it to
the state to pursue those charges if
they decide to it was the state that
pursued the initial charge but the
president has expressed his complete
dismay with those actions
Levante 'if i do you think it's
important to note that they are a big
element of his protest agents noted that
ambassador O'Brien has noted that we
have ample evidence that DOJ has
received indicating that an tyfa is
responsible for that unrest but as to
exactly how and chief has identified
that would be it more of a question they
certainly could be responsible for
unrest but they are not the majority out
there guys I mean look we're looking at
every tool and the in the federal
toolkit available to us you know ideally
this would have been resolved at the
state level the states after all have
the police power embedded in the Tenth
Amendment and it is their responsibility
to patrol there's their streets but
you're right to say that there are many
federal authorities including the one
you cited available to us the the focus
of the call with the governor's was
really the National Guard not that
specific tool and the toolkit that you
mentioned but the National Guard and how
it should be utilized much stronger than
it's currently being utilized I guess I
will go to see Jeff talk about this more
Oh [ __ ] whitmer she said she found the
president's call so gently disturbed it
and she said that I've been trolled the
governor's they need to put it down or
they would be overwritten so what I mean
is it or specific Authority is easy
because as you know what Sedona does the
army yeah I don't know why governor
Whitner Whitmer would be dismayed at the
president telling governor's to do their
job it is their responsibility to police
their street from police power said
Constitution so bad you have quite
clearly many of them failed to do their
job look at the scenes we have seen and
it's gotten to the point where today the
president has said enough is enough you
know there are tools I can use namely
deploying National Guard and many others
that Steve cited one the insurrection
act it's one of the tools available
whether the president decides to pursue
that that's his prerogative right now
we're looking at a focus on the National
Guard that's where it currently stands
and you know there's a distinction
between the National Guard and military
forces in the solutely awful you know
the last 24 hours we saw more
cooperation between protesters and law
enforcement and were it not for stuff
like we're gonna put the chairman of the
Joint Chiefs in charge and scale up the
military response we could we could be
de-escalating we could be productively
de-escalating my fear is the exact
opposite will happen tonight I won't put
a number on it I think it's incumbent on
governors to look at the situation you
know a case in Texas might not merit the
same thing as you know New York City so
he's encouraging the governor's to up
those levels but there's not a specific
number that he has in mind David
the president is hiding in the bunker on
the racial protest issue he was
literally put in the bunker on Friday
night by the Secret Service
indeed I mean would you agree that he is
hiding out on this issue and as I know I
would not I would not agree I don't look
I was on the phone with the president at
least half a dozen times yesterday and
every time I talked to him he was
telling me about a different action he
had taken whether it was talking to a
governor about this or foreign leader
ventilators this president has believed
that was generals yesterday he's each
and every moment they spoke very
strongly on the phone and they talked
about ventilators streets where the
governor's have failed he stepped in
he's acting he's hard at work you've
heard from him on this issue any number
of times
I mean he's working because that's the
job of the president is to keep this
country safe
I really think that's a misnomer in the
media you know it was really appalling
some of the coverage I saw like the New
York Times yesterday yeah this is not
the type of president who improves
things by giving speeches so we will not
we are gonna have him tweet instead team
they made a cursory mention of his
remarks at space force but most of which
at least half of which pertained to
George Floyd there was a Washington Post
article with an egregious headline about
Trump staying silent
he hasn't been silent on this I have a
whole list of his remarks there and
instead paragraph 23 they know oh wait
we're contradicting our own headline the
president did in fact make remarks
contrary to the silent headline you had
Don Lemon on CNN saying at 9:38 p.m. on
Saturday night the president's been
silent right this is all about what Don
Lemon said at 22 minutes to 10:00 p.m.
last night that's what really this all
hinges on CNN double down the next day
Sunday afternoon saying the president
was silent and you know I don't want to
bore you with reading out all of his
statements but it sounds like I should
read a few like the president saying
it's a grave tragedy that filled
Americans all over the country with
horror anger and grief and I stand
before you as a friend and Ally to every
American seeking justice he said I
understand the pain the people are
feeling I can go on and on but I would
just be repeating what the president has
already said because make no mistake
this president has not been
silence and at this moment he is acting
to protect this country from the
lawlessness we saw just out here no
Lafayette to our classmates yes yeah
particularly egregious act bank John's
Church Church of the presidents was
targeted last night for food he all over
set up and fire what is the president's
reaction to that please it's hurtful
honestly it's hurts on a number of
levels work va was to face literally the
word veteran spray-painted out of the
placard in front of the department guys
tan suit was so disrespectful by the way
memorial defaced how does that make much
sense the place where the march on
Washington began that moat that
momentous occasion in the history of
civil rights that memorial was to face
last night that doesn't honor the legacy
of George Floyd it doesn't and certainly
not the burning of st. John's Church but
the st. John's I think it's important to
go through a little bit of this but
Reverend John C Harper was the st.
John's rector many centuries ago at
least decades centuries and a few
decades ago and here's what he was told
he was told he needed to close st.
John's because he couldn't leave it open
for the march on Washington because
quote it might be a bloodbath but he
stood boldly he stood boldly and he
stood on the side of justice and on the
day the march on Washington being so
prepared for [ __ ] that you have a
page of historical events to read from
when the questions are where the hell is
the president like it's it's not she was
reminded of this store she planned to
read a page of random history to not
answer actual questions about what Trump
is doing church that was burning last
night here is what they said taking that
bold stance to support Martin Luther
King they said this this church building
is open as it has always been so all who
want to worship here the ministry of
this parish is extended to any who seek
it our fellowship with one another has
no limitations whatsoever that church
supported the bold civil rights moments
of the march on Washington which began
at the Lincoln Memorial
that doesn't honor the legacy of George
you can rap on this it doesn't cause and
those are violent anarchists an tyfa who
are taking advantage of the pain of
people the pain of the peaceful
protesters it's inexcusable and we have
to stand as one America against the
burning of the church and a defacement
of the Lincoln Memorial
Chanel Oh God this administration
investigate either members of Congress
or political organizations who are
funding or ties to it
yeah you know auntie phytic at this
point we're pursuing the domestic
terrorism angle that's the DOJ has
decided and what was your first question
was about martial law the first one was
both national monuments and yes so I
have not heard that discussed yes Putin
and if so considering what the president
said to governor's later in the day
did he ask President Putin for advice on
how to twelve arrests and he's not going
to tell us I don't have any details on
that call I wasn't a part of it but and
I am not entirely certain what was
discussed but the call did take place
does the president regret using phrases
like when the shooting starts the
looting stop shooting starts and prays
like Bischoff stocks is he considering
apologize like those crazy so the
President on the diluting point he was
taken wildly out of context Twitter it's
interesting to watch I've seen multiple
instances of real incitement of violence
on Twitter but my driver penalized those
users like for instance Iran we've seen
horrific tweets from the Iranian regime
about the elimination of the Zionist
regime to quote them and that was never
flagged interesting that their gut
instinct was to flag the president and
they did so in an accurate way the
president very clearly laid out what he
meant by that tweet that looting leads
to shooting and we have seen the
unfortunate killing of one person in
Minneapolis there were seven people shot
in a st. Louis riot a few nights ago and
the president clearly laid out what he
meant but it is interesting to watch the
gut instinct of Twitter to go ahead on
and label which president somehow
inciting violence which it absolutely
was not but look I want to say this we
cannot let violence and we cannot let
looting and a few bad actors divide us
as an American people I'm the American
spirit before she said the protests have
been taken over by an Tifa everywhere
and that's why this is all about NT fun
now she says you know really it's just a
few bad actors some things that we
haven't seen and I think it's important
for the American people to see them and
Judd I'm gonna call for that sound by
now of some video that I think it's very
important for us all to know
if you want to be with y'all for real so
I took my helmet on delayed the protons
down yeah this guy's great wanna make
this a parade now one ounce of damage
nobody's arrested
[Music]
I think these are great images and I
played some of them on my show today
this has nothing to do with Trump's
leadership at all it just has nothing to
do with it
[Music]
[Music]
Louisville a human chain protecting an
officer separated
[Music]
Trump so great right that these things
happen it's like how stupid do you have
to be we've seen examples of police
protecting protesters and protesters
embracing police and it's been beautiful
to watch though those images have not
been played all that often and I don't
want to leave you with a quote from
Martin Luther King jr. that we must
learn to live together as brothers or we
will perish together as fool's that's it
thank you get the hell out of here yep
I gotta go gotta go gotta go really
really stunning stuff guys I mean just
incredible incredible that that even
counts as a press briefing absolutely
unbelievable thanks to everybody who
jumped in on the stream I really really
appreciate it so many of you signed up
and grabbed memberships I want to say
thanks to Pat Osborne who was number
five Ozzy Osbourne number six very much
appreciate that Patricia Betts old is
number seven also Alan oddly grabbed the
membership on my website Jan ov Gregor
was new member number nine I would be
remiss if I forgot about Joanne sharp
new member number ten also angel
Melendez and Matthias Hummel all taking
advantage of the coupon code 2020 now so
appreciate everybody who joined me I do
plan on some protests streaming but I do
need material for what should my source
streams be local news will immediately
trigger copyright strikes against my
channel so if folks want to help me out
with some reliable just regular people
who are streaming from protests I'm glad
to jump on and do some of that coverage
in the meantime please remember if
you're watching me on Facebook hit the
like button if you're watching on Twitch
make sure you're following my channel
and if you're watching on YouTube of
course hit that subscribe button I'll be
back with you guys very very soon
you